welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you're still
in the dark of a dark then this is the
video for you we recently put together
an ending explain for the third season
and now we covered the main topics
judging by your comments there's still a
lot of questions hanging over the finale
as a thank you to everyone keeping the
conversation going I thought I'd do an
additional video to answer all of the
things that you still might be confused
about throughout this will be going over
who Regina's father is how Jonas ended
up looking like Deadpool how Claudia
knew of the origin world the point of
the show and a lot more obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
season yet then I highly recommend that
you turn off now and don't interact with
your future self at all now please drop
a thumbs up if you enjoy the video
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our Q&A of dark okay so
the first question you might have had
when finishing dark is what was the
point Adam and Eva have been in a
constant war with one another because
the former believes that if he destroys
the origin then that will end the time
loop juxtaposing this Eva doesn't want
her child to die and thus she will do
whatever she can to make sure that it
continues in the finale
Adam accomplishes his goal but he
doesn't disappear realizing that
destroying the origin was not the way to
end the loop Moranis Eva wants the loop
to continue so in the end neither can
really win in the finale we learned that
both the dimensions we'd seen throughout
the season were actually offshoots of an
origin world in order to stop these
paired cycles of endless misery Adam and
Eva or rather Jonas and Martha had to
travel to the source and stop time
travel from being invented in order to
stop their worlds from being created
they managed to do so but it completely
erased their existence and as Martha
said they ended up being what was
basically a dream this was hammered home
by Hannah in the final few minutes who
stated that she had what felt like a
dream wash over her at one point in
which she felt the happiness that the
characters gained upon dying but what
exactly was the point if it was all a
dream well the death of the universe
actually ties back to why they were
created in the first place
that was to save ten houses son after a
big argument merrick ran out into his
storm with his wife and their child and
they were killed during a traffic
accident this May tano's obsess over
time travel and he created a time
machine in order to stop them that night
and thus saved their lives
so while stock might seem like there was
actually no point to it at all there
really was and we saw firsthand that
these two alternate realities did save
ten houses family even if they did so
inadvertently so tan houses goal was to
save his family and he managed to do
this in the end by creating two worlds
in which a pair of Heroes would unite
and carry out the act for him this was
unintentional but the end sort of
justified the means and he managed to
achieve his goal which in my opinion was
the point of the show however the
characters in their worlds to also wish
to end the constant cycle of darkness
and this was reflected in Claudia who
had to watch her daughter die numerous
times now this brings us on to our next
question which is how did Claudia know
of the origin world
well first off Claudia is an extremely
intelligent woman not only was she the
head of the power plant she also managed
to navigate the loop several times and
used Adam and Eva as chess pieces in a
game to ultimately correct everything
Claudia actually understood the loops
and time machines whereas I don't think
that Adam and Eva did this is why Adam
found it extremely difficult to
construct one without being burnt in the
same way that you and I can use a
computer I doubt we could actually build
one from scratch which is why Adam and
Eva were both puppets constantly looking
to her for advice now Claudia actually
figured out that there was an Origin
world because she realized that regina
couldn't be traced back fully into the
family tree and therefore must exist
outside of it in another world
no Regina's father was thought to be
truant a Claudia knew this wasn't true
and thus she must have been conceived in
another way pretty much erasing the
possibility of both dimensions that
she'd visited being the true one she
also realized that though humans tend to
think in dualities such as light and
dark day and night that would actually
have to exist a world in which both
aspects were coexisting as one the
triquetra is pretty much how the
timeline actually looks instead of the
infinity symbol
that we saw Eva understanding it as the
number three is also laced throughout
doc such as there being time jumps of
thirty three years the predominant
travelers being in groups made up of
three such as Jonas Martha and Claudia
there being three versions of most the
protagonists such as the younger
middle-aged and older versions the
series being three seasons long and so
on and so on yeah she probably didn't
know that last one however everything
existed in stages of three and thus that
would have to be a third world you sort
of had to take a leap of faith with her
knowing this but you also have to
appreciate that she'd been around these
loops so many times that she picked up a
lot of things now the next question you
may have is well how did Claudia come
back to life well as we discover with
Jonas who is killed at one point there
are several switch points in which time
can loop around in a certain direction
eventually coming back to a certain
point and then continuing the loop once
more however if you change these switch
junctions you can reverse something and
this is pretty much what Claudia did an
example of this is shown through Martha
who at one point has the option to
either save Jonas or not she was aware
that she could do it either way or ebo
way sorry pun intended and was aware
that there were possibilities to make
choices Adam was unaware of this and no
Eva was she just wanted to continue the
loop in which his son lived forever so
she didn't let him know Claudia
discovered it too and it was only upon
informing Adam of it in the finale that
he realized that he could make choices
as well so basically Claudia survived
because she used the uno switch card and
got herself out of it in the end so that
she could travel to Adam and tell him
the truth everything she did was to save
Regina so she may have even let an
alternate version of herself die in
order to make it so that she could
appear in the finale and guide add him
away from continuing the loop this saves
the world and also leads to a lot of the
characters getting a happy life in this
happy life we see that Regina is in fact
alive and also learn who her father
really is now it's given to us in a
picture frame but we actually discover
that it was in fact burned that was a
dad burn did flirt with the younger
Claudia and we learned that he later
ended up marrying her
we share draw your own conclusions over
that however this has been confirmed on
the dock website so we now know
officially it is the case it also has to
be as Regina pretty much proved the
origin world exists through her father
who existed outside the loop so we can
confirm that it is indeed the case
the next question you're likely have is
how did Adam get those scores now this
isn't a case with the Joker where
there's multiple options but it is
something that you sort of have to draw
your own conclusions over so the reason
that this question has been raised is
because we were told that giannis got
them because of traveling however we
know that several other characters
traveled and the only real scar that
Martha got was to cut on a cheat which
was given to her by a fence and also the
one handed to her by IVA so she
remembered her duties so why did Adam
have these and not anyone else well at
the star of episode 7 we see that the
older version of Jonas is badly burned
by the machine and thus we can gather
from this that as he was building it he
would have received more and more burns
trying to perfect the device I would
have loved to have seen the moment he
ended up going Freddy Krueger but
unfortunately we didn't get the chance
to and just have to make up our own
minds on it I guess what we know is a
drop and what we don't know is an ocean
thank you very much now back to the
happy ending to just clear everything up
firstly Jonas and Martha are not alive
and it's unlikely that the versions we
saw will ever be Jonas was of course
created from Mikkel Martha's brother who
time travelled and as we see things have
massively changed in terms of the family
trees so it's unlikely that he'll come
back
how about Hannah does state that she
plans to name her child Jonas you can
either take this as the character coming
back and no longer being trapped in a
loop or simply just as a tribute
personally I lean more towards the
former because I'm sentimental like that
but also this would be a completely
different Jonas due to his father not
being there similarly this is reflected
in Ulrich and Charlotte who are not at
the dinner table either now firstly
Ulrich is not there because he was
created due to the time loop he was the
son of truant a and the grandson of
Agnes and the unknown
the unknown was the child of Jonas and
Martha who were his great-grandparents
which makes him part of the loop and
therefore if they aren't alive then he
can't be either throughout the seasons
Erick was a cheat and he didn't really
appreciate what he had and caused a lot
of pain and suffering to those around
him so I think in order to have a
paradise
he just wouldn't be there to inflict the
misery and is possible I even if Martha
and Jonas are born that he will never be
made Katharina is also not wearing a
wedding ring anymore so it does seem
like the two never got together
mirroring this shali does not exist at
all in this reality as she was primarily
born of the loop with her daughter
Elizabeth becoming her mother and so on
this is why she's not present here
however it is possible that she still
continued in some form or another like
Jonas
we know that the tan house family
survived and thus she may have ended up
becoming his grandchild as she was in
the original world now that pretty much
wraps up all of the questions except for
what happened to wool as I it's
something that sort of been a running
joke throughout the entire series with
the character being cut off every time
he goes to explain how he damaged it
it's sort of become the Nick Fury of Doc
and many fans have pored over exactly
what could have caused it and how it
came to be that way
now I don't want to disappoint anyone so
I've gone through all my notes and
behind the scenes information and have
finally traced back everything to give a
final answer and exactly how the
character lost it now we learn that it
happened in the summer beforehand and
clearly well I had to cover up exactly
what it was and didn't want people to
know however we finally finally know
that it came